well since it absorbed thousands of
unskilled migrants from Central America
came up in that Caravan Tijuana Mexico
should be well on its way to becoming
one of the world's richest cities at
least you think so based on what you
hear every day or read in The Washington
Post but surprisingly many people in
Tijuana are upset we've interviewed a
couple of times an elected official a
municipal delegate called Honora Lopez
we talked to the other night and he
suggests that the caravan has not
actually been that good for Tijuana
itself they're still here problems are
still going on there's been like 280 at
rest it before it was only for drug
possession and being drunk in the
streets now it's for breaking and
entering into homes people have even
made fiercest arrests of them and things
aren't very nice here around the
neighborhoods is tired of them the
merchants at the school so what exactly
is the matter with these people in
Mexico why don't they like this Caravan
Ethan Behrman is a California radio host
enjoy society thanks all for coming on
so I guess the reason we keep going back
to this topic and let me just stipulate
as I have before with you that I like
immigration I like immigrants I give
every person in the caravan the benefit
of the doubt I think most really do want
to come here for a better life what
infuriates me is that nobody gives the
residents of any country into which
immigrants for the benefit of the doubt
all of them are dismissed immediately as
big as if they don't like it what's so
striking is that nobody on the left is
saying anything about the reaction of
Mexican citizens and Tijuana to this
Caravan who were sounding like Donald
Trump all of a sudden why are people
ignoring this I don't know that they are
ignoring it because we definitely
recognize the plight of human beings
that have crossed from one of the
poorest countries in the world that had
36 years of civil war and is now the
conduit of the cartels for exporting
drugs to the United States and that's
what we're talking about with these
people who are camped out there you know
there there are issues obviously anytime
you take a couple of thousand people and
stick them in a stadium and tell them to
just wait there with an unknown amount
of time before they're going to be
processed for asylum you would have
trouble with an unknown amount of time
that you're stuck in a place is well
while you're trying to figure out how to
bring your family to a country I believe
that it probably wouldn't engage in any
home invasions during that time but you
know who knows maybe it's a situational
response but here's what I'm saying so
struck by is everybody I talked to says
we have deep sympathy for the plight of
these migrants and and I said at the
outset and I mean it I have sympathy too
I've never heard anybody in the left say
you know we have deep sympathy for like
normal people we just want to pay their
taxes and send their kids to school and
their lives are being overturned by this
there's an effect on the people who live
there wouldn't do people come and nobody
cares about them at all even in Tijuana
nobody cares about them why is that well
I think people do care about them but
well here's the issue we have problem
one we wait can we have we have a
problem of governments failing but both
Mexican and US government's failing to
deal with this human refugee crisis and
then the people are stuck with that
problem in the local community
especially in places like Tijuana and on
top of it all yeah we always have a
problem with the other there are
deep-seated issues of em sure what
you're saying is the people of Tijuana
are bigots and and before we reach that
conclusion I think it's fair to look at
the facts so there is at least one
school in Tijuana that's been closed for
three weeks because they can't open
people want to send their kids to school
in Tijuana in any place there's trash
all over the streets it's super
expensive and there's been a crime spree
so all I want from you and from everyone
on the left is an acknowledgement that
there are real concerns that are not
rooted in bigotry but that are rational
and it's fair to be upset about this but
no one will give the benefit of the
doubt to normal people ever why oh
there's definitely a right to be
concerned about trash and and the
inability to send your kids to school
and the environment and everything else
rhyme but again miscellaneous I've got
to figure out who yeah of course you can
be upset you should be upset about crime
yeah and that is a problem but you have
to look at what the causes are and who's
responsible for what is actually
happening you're taking people who have
a problem with getting food 67% of
people from Guatemala have an inability
to have regular access to food
of extreme poverty they're still dealing
with the aftermath of a 36 year civil
war they're still dealing with the
aftermath of the United company that the
United States sent down it was a tough
yes we did the Terminator
okay but okay but again I see all these
religious figures very self-righteous
religious figures show up and say we're
on the side of the migrants why do I
never see anybody show up and say we're
on the side of just a normal people of
Tijuana who aren't rich and have prosaic
concerns like the rest of us why does no
one if on the left ever go up and say
we're gonna stand up for you well I'm
not sure I have a good answer for you
there because the government and the way
the system is set up is for the citizens
that are there in places like Tijuana or
here in the United States and we're
talking about a refugee crisis that's
happening an asylum crisis leader of
human beings and children we just had
the seven-year-old who died crossing
over it's Texas but I mean what about so
we have a responsibility I guess we also
responsibility to the people who already
live in Tijuana and already live in this
country and they feel like no one cares
about them and that's why they elected
Donald Trump so like someone should care
about them or else they're gonna get
matter don't you think well of course I
do care about my father I clearly do but
the issue is again you can't just kick
people to the curb because you don't
like them because they're refugees and
we view people of different
socioeconomic status with with a bias
implicit bias go take the Harvard one of
their tests from Project implicit it's
it's a virus but I say watch how you
feel you lined up online thank you